for as long as I can remember I've had  this fascination with old abandoned  racetracks  [Music]  kind of places where my granddad and my  father raced where my heroes traded  paignton with their rivals I'm about to  embark on a journey to see and feel the  soul of my sport you really feel the  presence of others and you almost wanted  to look around and see if they were here  it's like their spirit had stayed here  I'm Dale Earnhardt jr. get ready to come  along with us tracing the footsteps of  Forgotten racing history uncovering some  of the greatest characters and stories  the sport has ever known  for nothing is lost that can't be found  and nothing exists that can't be  cherished  you